Hi, I'm Bruce Tripido, Associate Vice President of Product Marketing here at Sharp Electronics.
And we're here at our CES booth and two of our primary themes here at the booth for 2011...
...are Quattron technology. Quattron is Sharp's four color technology for LCD TVs.
We're the only manufacturer that has the four color technology.
And our other theme this year is making bigger better with Quattron technology.
So Sharp is launching this 70 - inch class screen size here at the show.
All told in 2011, we'll have about five series of 70 - inch class TVs.
The models that we're looking at here, these are 70 - inch full array LED with backlight,...
...with local dimming capability.
These are all connected TVs with our most up-to-date wireless connected platform.
Some of our higher end 70 - inch TVs have 3D capabilities as well as 240 hertz.
And the primary message, as you can see here,...
...is that Quattron technology makes bigger better.